let's move on to uh after you returned
from the bahamas you said you obtained a
document showing detailed accounting of
tethers holding
which included quote billions of dollars
of short-term loans to large chinese
companies
yes
and you know i'm being a little some
people have asked like why i didn't post
the document or give more details and
you know i'm giving as much as i as i
can um got it you know how to reveal
your source i guess would be exactly
a little uh keep it a little vague um
but perfect there's a lot of question
about
does tether have this chinese commercial
paper a lot of people were sort of were
saying on twitter that they do
and
i found what i believe to be this
trustworthy document that shows that yes
like they have a lot of chinese
commercial paper um not
uh ever grant which was the
property developer that's like teetering
on the edge of bankruptcy or whatever
right
these documents before evergrand
collapsed
correct
yeah these are these predate that and
there's uh
and i didn't see evergrand in there
got it okay and so it was detailed to
the level that it showed the actual
holdings um is what you're saying
because every gram wasn't listed which
means other people existed
i feel like i would have but who knows
you know in this story it's like so hard
to know what to
what to believe i mean there's no pile
of gold right like in the end like how
do you almost start wondering like how
do you prove anything
about well i mean it just shows that the
banking system uh the global banking
system combined with crypto i would
think you uh would agree on anybody
listing would agree creates a great
opportunity to obscurify uh what's
actually happening right and in fact
tether is an obscurification pool right
people can buy tether
they could
you could be a criminal you could be the
vatican anybody in between
i guess some people would consider the
vatican more on the criminal side but
putting that aside
you know you could be anywhere in
between those two a you know a virtuous
non-profit or a you know terrorist
organization anybody could buy towers
move them around and there's very little
way to figure out what's going on at
least by journalists so when you get
this document um let me ask this
question how sure are you and how does a
journalist broad strokes without being
specific to this case what is the
process of vetting a document like this
without revealing your sources which i
i'm sensitive to
um because it's a whistleblower
obviously or somebody who can have
serious ramifications for giving you
this information how does one um
as a journalist make sure that you're
not being actually manipulated
and somebody's not trying to do an
operation on you because the people who
are running tether seem very colorful
perhaps um
you know some people would consider them
to be dishonest uh i think and people
have some concerns about them so did you
ever think maybe somebody's sending you
a forged document to make bloomberg look
bad and then how does an organization a
journalistic organization that has a
very big reputation like bloomberg make
sure you're not getting snowed
yeah i mean there's always a risk like
anything um it's certainly something i
worry about i mean it depends um
how much you
trust the source
um correct and
the
sometimes you're able to verify some of
the details independently um
got it and corroborating evidence that
you get from the documents right you
could look at the letterhead and make
sure that's official letterhead you can
look at the data inside of it and make
sure that that data seems legitimate
yeah
you could you could check some of the
data with other sources um and also um
i mean i think people have a lot of like
misconceptions about how journalism
works i'm not saying you but like
sometimes i don't realize how little
people unders i think everyone's going
to know how this works and they don't um
like i wouldn't just
exactly i mean i'm a journalist the
reason i asked the questions for the
benefit of the audience so that they
could look into your process because you
do think deeply before publishing
something like this correct i mean we
would we wouldn't just get something in
the mail like an anonymous thing and be
like oh yeah i've seen it like for sure
you know like we're yeah
if we put it in there it's because we
believe it to be true we've got reason
to do so and i wish i could have been
more if
uh
specific in the story but probably the
best i could do you know i mean
eventually you you probably will be at
some point as the ramifications happen
so let's
uh you see they have you know billions
of dollars in these short-term learns to
large chinese companies one would wonder
why would they take that risk and then
the next one is that they uh were giving
loans
uh or making investments i guess they
would be loans to other crypto
companies using bitcoin as collateral so
i assume the other companies bitcoin
would become the collateral of tether
so
am i correct in assuming they're taking
these high risk loans from the chinese
companies to get the
uh a better return because they're high
risk they have higher return because
they carry the risk but in the second
case of giving money to crypto and then
owning their bitcoin
is this a savvy move because if they are
investing in those kryptos companies and
they're enabling crypto
they know crypto they know crypto's
growing they have inside information
essentially because of their data um
knowledge right but they also then get
to own their bitcoin as collateral and
bitcoins going up so if they do go bust
they get that benefit we don't know
what's in these documents maybe they get
an interest rate that's really good but
in a way
this is like
somebody who
um
i don't know selling somebody who sells
houses giving people the loans to buy
the houses without doing a background
check on them
you know and like that could pop prop up
the entire ecosystem is that the issue
here so
they're giving like these loans aren't
too complicated it's like this
i was explaining this by um
the
founder of celsius which is like a big
sort of quasi bank prime broker type
company so he's got too many bitcoins he
wants um
tethers instead so he'll give tether say
and don't quote me on these numbers but
let's say he gives tether a million
dollars worth of bitcoin
that's collateral
to hold on to temporarily tether will
lend him
seven hundred thousand dollars worth of
tether
so even if the price of bitcoin goes
down a fair amount they're still covered
and
celsius pays tether
he said five or six percent interest so
that's like
i mean you can see why they do this i
mean it seems pretty safe like
as far as things go especially in the
bitcoin world and five or six percent uh
interest is pretty good you know even um
yeah
i mean if you on a billion dollar loan
that's what he said or a billion tether
loan um
that's 50 million bucks a year um right
so
this this uh is a pretty profitable
deal for them and if you believe in
bitcoin you might think it's not too
risky now
i mean the thing that we're not talking
about here is like
tether is uh if you compared it to say
like a a money market fund i mean these
funds
take like
very very little risk because
there's this one big risk which is that
if people lose confidence in the fund or
in tether
they might say okay
i think tether might have lost some
money in secret
it's like a game of musical chairs like
i better cash out right because if i'm
the last one the money could be you
could have a bank run basically and you
don't want to be the bag holder yeah
because if these loans were to fail
uh
there would be a uh this sort of
uh shock wave
people start pulling out they start
selling their tethers trying to cash
them in or whatever maybe it could go
below a dollar because tether doesn't
have the
assets to back
hey everybody i thought i would bring
christina
cassiopo i pronounced it correct i'm
hoping chris you got it yep all right
you're the founder of vanta
people have been hearing your ads on the
pod for the last year and i thought it'd
be fun to have you on and you to explain
why you created vanta and what sock 2 is
and why it's important people get it
right so let's start with what is sock 2
for people who are just realizing they
have to become sock too compliant
for sure so sock 2 is at a high level
it's sort of a customer asking you to
prove your security got it and when you
do a sock to report how often do you
have to update it and what is that
process like because my understanding is
you don't just do this once in the life
of your company you do it continually
every year every quarter right so you
actually do it annually yeah so often um
so the way these reports work is they've
got dates and time periods on them um
and sort of like a pen test it's
something once you start doing you'll
just renew every year all right
fantastic well thanks so much for coming
on and telling the audience uh why you
should get your sock 2 when you should
get it and how you should do it and
you've been very nice to our audience
giving them a thousand dollars off which
is a really significant
uh and generous offer go to
vanta.comtwist
v-a-n-t-a.com twist to get a thousand
dollars off your sock too thanks
christina appreciate it thank you so
much cheers now